laser there's a story i should tell you
so which was a year ago october in june
of 2019
i took 11 guys to scotland to play golf
all right so five of us were on
a british airways on a friday night june
25th that left kennedy at 6 30
and at 8 30 at night the pilot comes on
and says could the head steward come to
the cockpit
immediately we have an emergency so the
head
steward goes in the pot goes into the
cockpit immediately and the pilot comes
out and says listen
we've had a power failure and the backup
unit is not working
and we feel there's heat coming out of
the overhead compartments
so everybody stands up and feels it so
we're going to have to make
an emergency landing in gander
in newfoundland but he gets the plane
down fire trucks everybody comes on in
the
plane everything else standing ovation
on the plane and engander for 17 hours
before we could take off again
what a that when i went through that a
year and a half ago
i felt that maybe god's gonna give me a
few more years left that was pretty
scary that's the scariest it's been for
me
so what went through your mind when that
was happening so the fact i wasn't alone
and i was with four good friends i think
it kind of helped
but there is no other you know that's
the closest i've been on a plane where
it was scary
i was you know i prayed to god you did i
said
i sure did did you know you were
religious yeah i was religious anyway
but
that delicious i mean i said god you got
to get us out of this you know one of
those did you reach out to anybody
besides god
well my five buddies that were sitting
right next to me we all looked at each
other says
i remember i told one guy john hutch
who's a big athlete went to hamilton and
he's usually pretty stoic
i said john what do you think he says
yeah i'm very very concerned when you
hear that from a guy that you respect
and usually is calm cool and collected
you get a little nervous you get along
did you guys did you guys hold hands
or were you masculine i did not hold
hands i didn't go that way
right right right you stayed right to
the end i didn't say the lord's prayer
but uh we were pretty happy when that
damn thing landed i can do a big 777 on
british airways
that that's the scariest one